Good morning John,  I hope that you don't mind this video today is not for you - it is for..
the aliens. Good morning aliens. I'm sure that your alien life and all of your alien business
has you very busy, so I wanted to give
you a really quick
sort of primer on our species so that it
may be just save you some research time.
While standing our height is roughly 3.77·10^10
times the average radius of a hydrogen atom, assuming that hydrogen atoms are the same size
where you are as they are for us,
which we think they probably should be.
We move around on two lower appendages
called "legs". We have two upper appendages called "arms" and each of  those arms has five
five appendages on them,
which we use to manipulate objects. A
final appendage on the top of our body
contains the majority of our sensing organs. We can detect chemicals in the air,
which we call "smell" . We can detect chemicals by
direct contact which we call "taste". We can
take in and perceive a certain range of
wavelengths of light and we can sense
vibrations carried through the air.
"Sound", or vibrations carried through the
air is the most important way that
humans communicate. We also communicate by
transferring the sounds that we make into
symbols which we can perceive visually
and understand. Our auditory forms of
communication are called "languages".
Unfortunately, many are spoken and if
two people speak two different languages, those two people will find it very
difficult to communicate. We get the
energy necessary for continuing our life
by consuming other organisms. Some of these
organisms get their energy directly from
our star - those are called "plants"
- while other organisms that we consume are more
like us. Production of these food
organisms requires a great deal
of the available land, area and fresh
water on our planet. While our bodies are
fueled by the consumption of other
organisms, our society is currently
fueled mostly by hydrocarbon compounds
that we find inside of our planet. These
compounds are burned to create the energy
necessary to heat and cool our dwellings,
produce light, produce goods, communicate
with each other, and move stuff, including
ourselves
around our planet. We are mortal. All of us
die, and so we must reproduce to pass our
genetic information to the next
generation. Two humans are required for
this process - a male and a female. The male
deposit his genetic material inside of the
female, where it is mixed together
and becomes a new human. This is one of our very
favorite things to do - we enjoy this process
a great deal. Human pairs will often bond
for life, though they're not always
male-female couples. Many times they are
female-female or male-male. Humanity also
very much likes to bond together into
groups. These groups are very much like
organisms in themselves. They pass
different ideas and world views among
themselves and between generations. Some of
these groups live together in
geographically defined areas. Those areas
are known as "countries". Countries contain
people who are all led by the same
government.
Countries will also occasionally go to war together, which means that they will
systematically attempt to  kill humans
inside of another country in order to
bring down that government. The most
common reasons for this are to spread
an ideology,
or to protect the citizens of your own
country ,or to gain control of natural
resources, such as the hydrocarbon
compounds that I mentioned. War on our world is
almost universally recognized as a
brutality, yet we continue the practice.
And it is worth noting that war has been
a key factor in the continuing
technological development of our
civilization.
People also organize themselves into
groups based on what deity they believe in.
If you don't know what a deity is,
they are divine all-powerful leaders who
control everything but don't let
themselves be known, except indirectly.
Not all humans believe in deities,
but most do.
Our society functions largely on the
trading of goods. We use something
called "money" to facilitate this trading.
Money is represented by pieces of paper,
sometimes metal disks and more and more
commonly, money is just a series of
numbers that is kept track of in our
global network. Without money it's
difficult to acquire food and shelter and
other basic needs. And there are still
people in our world who regularly die
because of their lack of money. Most of us
continue to find this very troubling but our
attempts to find better solutions have
not been entirely successful. We're running low
on fresh water. We're also running low on
the hydrocarbons that power our planet.
Alternatives, such as directly converting
sunlight into energy and using the power
locked within atoms are either dangerous
or not feasible. We have some experience with the
problems of population being solved
by starvation or disease or war, but humans
find this extremely distasteful.
If you have any guidance for us, please
send along any ideas that you have for
our culture to make it through to the
next stage of development. Thank you for
listening,
thank you for your time, have a nice day,
however
you measure days. John, I'll see you on
Wednesday.
John, nerdfighters, in comments below or
possibly in a video response I would like to
know
what you would say to the aliens if you
had a chance to talk to them, because I
found that a really interesting exercise.